اكثر من عشرين الف شخص هي جمله عدد
الفارين من الاشتباكات التي شهدها عدد من
المدن السودانيه خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
دخلوا الى جنوب السودان عبر معبر جودي
الجنوبي غالبيتهم من جنوب السودان والباقي
من جنسيات مختلفه نحن من يوم 17 حتى يوم
سجلنا اجمالي عدد
286 اسره
وعدده
الجانب الفردي 20,000
الاعداد لا تزال تزداد يوما بعد يوم في
الرحلات يرويها اصحابها بانها لا تخلو من
المعاناه والمخاطره
عندنا خمسه هنا الشمال كل حاجه كان
شايلينه في ايدينا تحت وزير الشؤون
الانسانيه الذي وصل الى معبر جودا الجنوبي
وصف الوضع الانساني بالكارثي مناشدا
المنظمات الانسانيه على تقديم الدعم
اللازم الوضع كارسي
والميزانيه في وقته ممكن ما يكفي عشان كده
مندي النداع
للمنظمات الانسانيه العالميه والمحليه اذا
في ظل هذه الاوضاع الانسانيه الحرجه تبقى
جوده معبرا يتطلع من خلاله الفارون
بالعبور الى المناطق الامنه داخل جنوب
السودان
الالاف من الحاربين من اتون الحرب التي
شهدتها عددا من المدن السودانيه عبروا الى
جنوب السودان عبر معبر جوده الجنوبيه وهم
يعدون العده بذهاب الى جبه او غيرها من
المدن الاخرى ولكن تذكره القبور تقف في
وجه الكثيرين منهم
العربيه
معبر جودا الجنوبيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات